>> Okay, fair enough, now of course if instead of reels,
we had complex result, okay, then we wouldn't have the same precondition, but
deciding what the form of the. Output is whether it's real or
complex is an important part of the specification process. For
this particular exercise, we're going to go with, go with the real numbers and
the precondition says that X which is our input argument is greater than or
equal to zero. Notice that were not saying what happens if.
X is less than zero. We're specifying the behavior of the function
in terms of what does this function mean when it gets expected arguments? Now,
if you wanted to have a variant. Which worked on any argument.
But race and exception or produced a return code if x was less than 0.
We could specify that as well. But we're going to keep it simple for
now and really say we're defining square root over the non-negative reels.